you probably don't need more learning
you need more courage more boldness to
do the thing and this is where a lot of
people will get stuck up is a oh I need
to learn more there's so many people
like if learning was the only thing that
mattered then University professors
would all be the richest people in the
world right I mean it's like the most
successful and they're not because
learning alone is not enough it's the
doing and so the most important part of
morning routine is the feeling you get
by the end of it you can get all the
strategies but if you don't believe in
yourself to be the person to do those
things you won't do the things you know
the perfect strategy in front of but if
you don't think that you're the guy who
can do it then you don't do
it so we're here with Hardy he's part of
the Mastermind group and as part of that
we're doing a one-on-one so how you
doing man how can I help what's on your
mind uh a lot of things on my mind I
don't even know where to start I was
thinking about this yesterday watching
some of other videos and kind of
thinking about what I want to ask you
that will actually make the change in my
business the thing that come up is I
identity somehow it's it's because I'm
looking back at my journey to where I am
right now it's people always know me as
oh hard's the civil engineer guy you
graduated and then you know that's all
you do for the last 25 years and now
you're doing this new thing and even my
family don't understand it right um and
that's that's kind of the challenge
that in a way I'm changing my identity
and try to do this new thing that people
don't really get
um it's tough like doing this basically
on my own and and that's thing the
challenge is like really come out uh
focusing on my why and why I'm doing
this and doing that shift is not easy I
find it it's really challenging this why
I want to ask you what I don't know you
you can I hear your story when you start
it up you have your own business but for
the first many years you're you're just
doing this it took a while yeah how you
kept going I know you said I just like
doing it but I was
like it it's I don't I don't know I just
try to get that message s things like I
just have to do it I just have to do it
but it it's hard when the environment is
like so who do you want to be I want to
be the best like meta I want to be the
best parents that I can be for for my
kids right and I will
be the uh best husband for my
wife and good example for for uh for my
community that you know I'm not just
doing civil engineering I want to make a
change um that I want to see in the
world especially in in the workforce I
don't think you know the background
several years I think seven years ago
now I got my anxiety attack first time
in my life I could not sleep um I was
working out of town in small town in
Alberta by myself and I just why awake
at night it's like I cannot sleep what's
going on I thought I got hit stroke I
went to the doctor and it's like oh all
good give you give me some sleeping pill
so I start sleeping a little bit but
then I had start having this Suicidal
Thoughts I was said what the heck's
going on right I've been by that time
seven years ago I've been doing personal
development on my own for 20 years so I
like okay don't want to take the pill I
know enough like yeah when I start
thinking about crazy things like that uh
stopped taking the pill and I start
doing my uh uh mindfulness meditation I
went back to doing mindfulness so my
head didn't go crazy and start doing my
journaling doing the positive journaling
get myself out of that but what happened
is
to
um I wonder how many people that not in
personal development know how to get
themselves out of it thing so I was
lucky enough that I got myself out
without the medicine I still can feel it
once in a while but I manage it really
really well now uh but that's the thing
and every time I hear about people you
know the suicide like two weeks ago
another friends uh from church uh their
uh their son ended up killing himself
just from stress at work and things I
was like man it is those kind of presses
like I can help guys I can help let's
talk to somebody like I around like
people around let's talk to people um
and also the other thing that really
pushed me off the edge is you know I put
my kids to private school I want them to
you know have the good education and
have a good uh uh kind of friends and
stuff and you know private school
Catholic School it's not it's not cheap
um so I just kep them to be be in a good
environment and even in the environment
think my sons a friend two of them I
killed himself too it's like how how is
our environment you know in the good
school and I know they're pretty well
off if they can put their kids there and
still happening like that's why like in
my head
like the foundation is back to the
family if the family is not there to
support the kids then things like this
going to happen that's why it's like you
know work is work yeah people has to go
you know business or work to make money
right but that's not the important thing
the most important thing is you know go
back to do your best for the family and
that's not something that I see is going
on right now that's why I was like H you
you learn all this stuff and you need to
get it out there and then tell people
about it and change right they I believe
that you know it's
not um luck that I learned all this
stuff like I believe that you know God
put that in me it's like you do all this
stuff you have all this things and I
take it on as my my own purpose to to
get the message out yeah that that
that's the thing
and if I can even just do a little bit
of change in in in our workplace and you
know families and get them back
especially to men you know like don't
just work you know if that's all what
you do then you know let let's sit down
and
talk that's really what's important
right now because you know my kids are
growing up right now uh they're all good
um thank God know me and we work hard in
raising them they're the future right
and try to get parents especially dad to
be hey you are the the head of the
house and it's not just all about
work
uh what's important for you let let's
let's make work and your house and your
life your relationship and your family
actually works it's not like one over
the other you know that that's what
happened a lot of times in in our
workplace it happened to me too my first
job I work for this company for 11 years
took me 6 months to
quit um it just miserable management
didn't go well and then I go home uh
miserable and until my wife's like why
don't you just quit already like you
come home in miserable like why do you
stick it out I think for the people
that's outside looking in it's EAS or
you just quit but for me it's like I
have to make this work I'm supporting
the family it's not as EAS as quit and
get another job at the time but and took
me six months I quit the job went to
another company and work with them and
same thing again like management issues
I quit again I quit like four times
right now and a lot of times it's more
like it didn't get managed well and they
all you know spending a lot of times at
work and I cannot be my best at home so
right now I'm I'm okay because I I see
value in what I provide to the company
and I have friends and they know you
know when we hire Hardy I can I can
vouch for him he can work hard and he'll
do his
work but a lot of people I think got
stuck in the mentality that I kind of
quit you know what going to happen if I
quit and they stick it out even though
they're unhappy and life is is not
working for
them so that that's the thing that that
that's what uh that's what I trying to
change you know George Foreman yeah what
do you what do you know about George
foran George foran I didn't watch the
movie yet I saw the movie is out uh is
there a movie out I didn't know that
yeah they they have a movie out about
him I haven't watched him yet when I say
George Foreman what do you think he's a
big guy yeah
um he yeah so is the boxer
champion
and I watched the trailer of the movie
so I kind of know a little bit what what
he's about like he's trying to get his
message out about about things right I
mean I hav seen the movie so I don't
know what what's in there but a lot of
people think of George Foreman as the
grill guy the George Foreman grill and
did you ever see his infomercials with
the George Foreman grill he's smiling
and he's happy and he's like this super
cheerful guy and by the
grill but for people who are old school
who know George hman from boxing he was
the bad
guy when he started in boxing he was the
bad guy he was the guy everybody hated
he leaned into the bad boy personality
like he was the bad guy of boxing and
why I bring it up is you talk about
identity where now unless you're OG
hardcore like boxing fici andado you
don't know any of that stuff you just
see him as this happy grandfatherly kind
of guy selling his grill ah and so when
you say that your background was you
know civil engineer I don't know you as
a civil
engineer you know the more that you
develop this new identity the less the
people who yeah there's some people who
currently know you as a engineer guy but
as you start to break out the new people
you meet they don't know you was Hardy
the civil engineer guy huh so a complete
identity shift uh is is possible not
just for you and your mindset and how
you see yourself but also just how the
world sees
you because when you're coming here I'm
not saying oh okay hard is going to come
teach me some civil engineering just got
to see him building the road right so I
think in terms of developing because you
can get all the strategies and we you
know we talk about a lot of the ideas of
Movie Makers but if you don't believe in
yourself to be the person to do those
things you won't do the things you know
they perfect strategy in front of you
but if you don't think that you're the
guy who can do it then you don't do it
right or it's like this start and stop
and start and stop and little tiny
progress and then nothing and it's like
okay I'm going to film a video like a
that was stupid who am I and then you
know yeah that's the thing it is this
things like oh it has to be perfect
because you know it has to be this it
has to be that
um and not until I start investing
heavily into into this right the
movement makers and master man is like
screw all that stuff you know got to
make this work so uh um yeah it's still
challenging not not going to say it's
not like I keep on telling myself like
it's uncomfortable because it's
unfamiliar it's not because I cannot do
it it's just haven't done it before and
not this a new thing um so so a couple
things that can help and and see then
what six because you looked at my
journey and and my goal is for people to
get there faster than me right it took
me a long time to build momentum
attraction and so all of us when we
learn something we want to then teach
the Next Generation to not have to
struggle and suffer as much as we did
right so like how how can we shortcut
that path do have to take so many years
a couple ideas I think can help the
first is why I asked you like who do you
want to be if you think about who Your
Role Models or heroes are and just
trying to be around them more whether
it's virtually or in person I mean
you're here you know learning from me
learning from the group um but virtually
too who are the people who help push you
to be the version of Hardy that you're
really proud of you know like the
ultimate version of Hardy uh for me
that's why I still make the videos on my
channel like the top 10 videos I make
for me cuz in the morning I want Oprah
in my ear and Elon Musk in my ear and
Steve Jobs in my ear because no matter
how great a day that I had it's still
starting up every day like today is
great today is like okay we got
Mastermind we're going to film it's easy
to get up for today right I barely slept
last night I just so excited to come me
here and be with you guys but on a on a
normal day it's like you're waking up
and there's nobody telling you what to
do and there's no kind of Boss over your
shoulder and sometimes it's hard to
connect to the big mission and so having
something you mentioned environment
having something that you feed into
yourself that makes you want to step up
and play a bigger game so for me it's
going for a walk and and watching one of
my videos not of me talking but of Steve
Jobs or whoever else right from my own
channel so I would still make the videos
even if nobody else cared or liked them
because I want them for
me so that by the end of my walk I'm
coming back think okay like let's go we
got to we got to do something here right
now it's not just a normal day and a
normal walk it's something that's
pushing you beyond your comfort zone and
getting excited for the thing that's
ahead right coming here you're flying
here to Toronto it's great right you're
going to get energy the next couple days
it'll be full of energy you go home have
more energy but then you know a week
later two weeks later it has a half life
and starts to dip so how do you how do
you maintain that energy level well it's
okay what else feeds you so if it's my
videos if it's somebody else's videos if
it's a if it's a podcast if it's books
if it's whatever it is that is a daily
habit if it's if it's a connection to
God and it's like prayer then but it's a
daily habit that makes you want to go
off and do something more bold and more
courageous yeah it's that's thing with
with the job too right like obviously my
my my job is like started at I liveed at
home around 6 come around like 6 s and
start shifting and and doing this kind
of things it's uh setting up that
environment
um like mentally I think like my job
like mentally it's
highing and trying to to I guess uh what
do I say consciously I guess shift it
okay after work's done I go home and
then start getting myself into into the
Rhythm how long of a time do you have
between work and when you get
home uh 40 minutes driving so what do
you do in those 40 minutes lately for
the last month been listening to our
training
okay it's always on but and what were
you doing before that so in the morning
I have another program I listen to so
driving to work I have I have the uh the
other program to talk about a book
usually we the unpack a book and what's
the lesson for the book so they gots me
to the work and then the job and then
when I live leave the work then a lot of
times right now it's our uh the the
training the the W makers training
okay and then at home obviously you know
have dinner and then family time and try
to work around you know the sit around
you know the living room with the family
and I'm working a lot of times I'm
working on something okay so you come
home and you have dinner with the family
and then you're working on your business
afterwards yeah so those transition
moments like really really matter so
first off it's great that you already
have some kind of yeah there routine r
set up the the thing to question with
routine though is like are you getting
the feeling that you need
[Music]
the feeling is there it's I think so I'm
trying to shift myself to more action
oriented right now because I got a lot
of learning in there you know lot so
it's like you probably don't need more
learning you need more
courage more boldness or doing to do the
thing right and this is where a lot of
people will get stuck up is like oh I
need to learn more I need to learn more
I need to learn more I need to learn
more there's so many people like if
learning was the only thing that matter
then yeah then University professors
would all be the richest people in the
world right I mean it's like and the
most successful and but they're not
because learning alone is not enough
it's the doing and so the most important
part of morning routine is the feeling
you get by the end of it you know if
you're thinking about how you even start
ask who you want to be you said I want
to be you started with I want to be a
great father then you said I want to be
a great husband then you said I want to
be a a role model for my community right
so that's actually the order of
priorities if I'm you I look at if you
just went and you work this job that you
you know you don't like and you're
trying to figure out a way kind of to
transition out of uh how do you make
sure you show up at home to be the best
husband and the best
father it's probably not listen in
movement maybe yeah I don't know I don't
know we talk much about
that like to get the vibe right so so on
the way home maybe it's actually better
to listen to
something else a parenting podcast a
medit you don't meditate on the way home
if you're driving but something that
makes you want to be a better father and
a better
husband but you don't even need action
steps like you don't need to necessarily
listen to a podcast to say here are the
eight ways to be a better
husband if you just felt like walking in
the
door I've put my work behind me for now
and I want to be a great husband
you'll come up with ideas of what to do
and you'll just be a better husband as
opposed to having to learn how to be a
better
husband or learn how to be a better
father like could you get more ideas
sure of course but you probably already
know enough all that's missing is the
intention in walking in the door that I
want to be a great father right now so
from whatever 5:00 to 7 o00 while I'm
home having dinner with the kids
everything else whatever that time frame
is I want to be a great father I want to
be a great husband even if it's only for
an hour it's not about the quantity of
time that you spend it's the it's the
quality right you can spend three hours
binging Netflix and lying on the couch
with your wife doesn't mean it's quality
time
together right yeah yeah so oh I have so
much going on I have my business I have
my family I have my job great but it's
not about quantity of time it's the
quality of of time so it's the mindset
going into the next task ahead so if
you're coming home what's a transition
to come home and of course you know I
want you to listen to Movie Maker
training it's great but at the same time
like if the goal coming home is I want
to be a great husband and a great father
well what do you need to feed into your
mind to help make sure that that happens
and maybe it's nothing yeah maybe you
just have a a picture on the what's the
thing that you fold down
black the light like maybe it's just a
picture of them in the car that's
actually a good idea and you spend 40
minutes just thinking about them on the
way home yeah because the thing is in my
head is like this all the time I have
you know other work to do to do the
business at the weekend but you can
still do work like it's you know it's
said 4 to s or 5 to 7 or or even six to
seven whatever it is and then you still
have an hour or two hours later on to go
work on your business but then at that
that hour if you're going to work from
you know 7 to 9: on your business or
whatever it is or 8 to 9:00 you only
have 1 hour day so making sure that
that's hyperfocused and then what's the
transition out from family time into
yeah work mode you know and then move
listen to well you may not have as much
time right I mean again it's it's less
about the to-dos and more about the
feeling because if you went into you
have a list of to-dos for your
business right you know what you need
Todo so you don't you don't mean to have
it all figured out but like you have
to-dos that you need to get done in your
business so the last thing that you need
is more training of what to do right so
I don't know what the morning program is
or the movie maker program uh like you
may not need more training now if you
only have an hour day to work on this
thing it's how do I show up and be a
courageous leader in my
business what do I need to do what am I
afraid to do that I need to do that that
you're overthinking and over in your
head and over over planning and over
over over over everything that if you
just showed up with the hearty that
needs to show
up you you'll just do the work so it's
less about like to-dos you have so many
to-dos you don't need more to-dos you
need to you need to do the
to-dos so why you're not doing the
to-dos it's it's the the mindset going
in so what do you need to do in the
morning to set yourself up for a great
day at work or maybe even get if you
work in eight hours you get it done in
six and work on your lunch break you
know like whatever you need to do in the
morning to have a great day at
work then on the way home I want to be
there for my my kids and my wife so what
do I need to do it honestly might just
be silence and just looking at a picture
of them yeah and decompressing from the
work and thinking how can I be a great
husband today yeah and then you're going
to do crazy you're going to may be crazy
you're going to like I'm going to stop
off and buy some flowers today yeah I'm
going to stop off and like and you just
come up with stuff because you're
thinking about them and you're you're
trying to be a great husband and a great
father yeah so it's like less inputs and
more Focus true does never haven't look
at it that way but no it does make a lot
of sense yeah and then the transition to
work whether it's at every night or
weekend or whatever you know you don't
have an hour transition or 45 minute
like if you have an hour to work every
night it takes you 45 minutes to
transition get right that's not going to
work so you need something faster to get
into the thing whatever the thing is and
uh for me one of the fastest things that
I do is just try to be of service
somehow to somebody so the fastest way
for me is the
comments it's like Instagram comments or
Instagram DMS or YouTube comments and
just messaging people like I'll do some
video messages I probably sent you a
couple video messages yeah while I'm
like walking outside or something heyart
Have I sent you something oh yeah yeah
okay good it's always when my day oh
Ione send me something I mean it's
nothing fancy I'm I'm walking outside
and I'm just making a video but it
connects me to why I do what I do what
would you suggest if people just
starting up though like I don't really
have DM to resp so part of the doing is
starting to make content yeah right so
and then in making content so you have
some people who follow you right now on
Instagram how many people follow you on
Instagram Instagram I know 100 100
people 100 perfect than got to check
that's great so here's I got 1500 in
LinkedIn well LinkedIn LinkedIn you can
do too just a little harder but but you
could still do it on LinkedIn but for
Instagram you have 100 people so start
before you go to work so the transition
home is I'm going to think about my
family and just be there for them but
then I'm going to I'm going to work for
an hour every night after dinner the
transition from family to work is you
send a video DM to somebody who follows
you you have 100 people now you're set
for the next 100 days but and and if the
100 days come up and nobody knew has
followed you but you go to the 100 list
again good idea right so I'm expecting a
video right she be like hey Evan just
wanted to say thank you for following me
on Instagram really means a lot to me
I'm trying to get my message out to the
world world and your support just
touches me thank you said whatever like
you speak from the heart like you're
just trying to connect to here's a human
being who thinks that your message is
valuable enough for them to follow you
so that can be at least for me it's a
quick shift to like this is why I do
what I do and so less
learning what more more feeling which
leads to more
doing yes i' I've been trying to uh make
that shift it's a
I said it's it's not easy because I'm
feeling more comfortable I guess on the
on the learning thing but yeah no it's
it's true it's
true and trying to get because I was in
the backround of mind when I started
doing you know the doing it's like I
better do it right I better do it I only
have an hour in the day here get better
do it right and then a lot of times he's
still trying to make it right is just
preventing it from actually doing it
just imagine your sitting down like this
and you're you're talking to the Hardy
in 5
years and you're telling Hardy in five
years that I haven't done
anything yet but I learned a lot yeah
right you be like dude you just wasted
little I like what are you doing like
five years
right so that's just a shift if you show
up with courage and it with courage in
every aspect of the life because you
said husband uh father husband and then
service Community if you did it every
day you're have to see some major gains
so homework today right after this is uh
to film a thank you video to somebody
who followed you not
me somebody else followed you and try to
try to feel it try to tap into it just
to really feel like this person decided
to follow you and how grateful you are
for them to be in your life and see how
that feels yes
all right let's go Ary thank you thank
you thank you no that's really big
that's really big thank you to watch me
coach another Mastermind member
oneon-one check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I remember talking to my dad and
telling my dad as a little girl when I
grow up I'm going to be an actress I'm
going to be writing and every report
card came with she talks too much if you
don't know what I'm saying let me
explain this to you